en fait j'avais pas l'information les
informations que j'avais sur scène de
voter via la télévision ya deux
véhicules d'entreprise funéraire qui
sont venus se stationner face aussi à
celle des c'est lui le kit est là devant
sainte dorothée vous certaines des
savons bien aller mais moi y avait rien
qui allait pour - là on était passé sur
les étages pour répondre aux besoins des
résidents une fois que le lui reprendre
c'était difficile de contrôler ses
fulgurances
c'était le matin il n'y allait pas bien
le soir est décédé le personnel les
cibles veulent en faire ghislain vivait
l'enfer et moss s'est ainsi h et celle
des qui se passe de présentation sainte
dorothée a été marqué au fer rouge au
printemps dernier sans un résident ils
sont morts de lakovic 19 d'autres ont
survécu dans un isolement presque totale
comme ghislain maintenant les projets
dans sont de retour qui était tellement
craintif et à vapeur de tous y avait
peur de se faire toucher refuser des
soins
et là ça s'est beaucoup amélioré par la
suite le personnel continue
tranquillement de se relever
cent soixante treize employés ont été
infectées la majorité sont venus au
travail sont traumatisés aussi s'ils ont
apporté la co vite dans leur famille que
c'est ça récent chaos même encore
aujourd'hui j'ai pas d'avoir lakovic et
par la donner à quelqu'un
marie sylvia j'ai dit on a l'impression
de vivre un choc post traumatique et ses
résidents qui ont survécu aussi ça le
crée beaucoup de zonage des résidents
sur tous ceux qui ont un petit peu plus
les fonctions cognitives alerte eux
c'est les autres m cette vague là parce
qu'il était vraiment isolé personnes
pleines et personnes entrées qui
restaient dans leur chambre ou manger
dans leur chambre pour les riffs audel
les effets de l' isolement
la dégradation de l'état de son épouse
atteinte de démence les bras à tous les
jours je lui demande on ne doit en fait
ce qu'elle est le nom que bon elle aussi
a survécu à la coved la famille a tout
fait pour garder le contact ont fait un
festin nu vous m'aimez plus voulait plus
me voir c'est bien peu celle qui paniqué
après un rapport dans quelques critiques
quand les problèmes de gouvernance de
communication ne manque d'équipements et
la mobilité du personnel
les choses ont changé donc ça c'est la
formation que tous les proches aidants
doivent suivre quand ils viennent
visiter à commencer par les équipes de
prévention des infections et le
dépistage
on a eu une petite frousse bleue trois
semaines oui un employé sortie post y
pleut et lors du dépistage hebdomadaire
une cellule de crise est alors
rapidement mises en place ont des puces
depuis ce temps là trois fois par
semaine les résidents et le personnel
qui travaille seulement sur sept étages
le puits aucun que est ressorti trois
employés se sont contaminés pendant les
pauses mais en les retirant rapidement
et en empêchant le mouvement de
personnel d'un étage à l'autre
l'éclosion s'est limité à ces trois cas
on n'aime pas eu d'explosion n'a comme
éteint avant que le feu arrive la
deuxième vague se limitera tel à ces
trois cas à sainte dorothée
les équipes en place l'espère la
communication et présente les directives
se rendent auprès des employés des
directives sont claires c'est pas pareil
c'est pas la même situation on est
prudent on est frileux on a peur on veut
pas que ça rende ici on n'a pas de coop
on n'en veut pas
parce qu'ils ont connu le pire de la
première vague celle angoisse qui pousse
l'extrême prudence a régné entre ses
murs une peur qui parfois semble s'être
dissipée à l'extérieur pour moi les gens
qui croient pas la cause unique parce
que ion police cusson a vécu parce qu'il
changerait d'idée issigeac audrey
charbonneau radio-canada laval